in this video i'm going to do some more
examples of simplifying radical
expressions but these are going to
involve adding and subtracting different
radical expressions and i think it's a
good tool to have in your toolkit in
case you've never seen it before so
let's do a few of these so let's say i
have 3 times the square root of 8 we
learned before that's actually the
principle square root of 8 or the
positive square root of 8
minus 6 times the principal square root
of 32. so let's see what we can do to
simplify this so first of all 8 we can
write that as 2 times 4 which is this
when 4 is a perfect square you might
already recognize that we could further
factor that into 2 times 2 but i don't
think we need 2 so we can rewrite
3 square roots of 8 as 3 times the
square root of 4 times the square root
of 2
right this is the same thing as the
square root of 4 times 2 which is the
square root of 8. so this term is the
same thing as that term
and then let's look at 32 we want to do
the square root of 32 32 is 2 times 16.
once again 16 is a perfect square so we
could stop there we could if you didn't
realize that you would factor that as 4
times 4 you'd see that twice you could
even go even further down to 2 times 2
and all of that but you see immediately
that's a perfect square so we can stop
there so this second expression can be
written as minus 6 times the square root
of 16 times the square root of
2. right this is the same thing
this right here i want to be clear it's
the same thing as a square root of 16
times 2. you can separate out the square
root of 16 times 2 is the square root of
16 times the square root of 2. we saw
that with our exponent properties
now what does this first term simplify
to this is 3 clearly this right here is
a 2 so you have 3 times 2 times the
square root of 2 that is 6 times the
principal root of 2
and then from that we're going to
subtract
well what's this term right here that is
positive 4 so 6 times 4 is 24 times the
square root of 2 and we're not done yet
if i have 6 of something and i'm going
to subtract from that 24 of that same
something what do i have i have 6
squares of 2 and i'm going to get
subtract from that 24 square roots of 2.
well this is going to be equal to 6
minus 24 is negative
18
square roots of 2. and hopefully this
doesn't confuse you remember if we had
6x minus 24x we would have minus 18x or
negative 18 x now instead of an x we
just have a square root of 2. 6 of
something minus 24 or something will get
us negative 18 of that something let's
do another one
let's say i have
the square root of 180
plus
6 times the square root of 405. so this
is really an exercise in being able to
simplify these radicals which we've done
before but you can never get too much
practice doing that so let's just do the
factorization of these right here so 180
is 2 times 90 which is 2 times
45
which is
5 times 9 and we could factor 9 down
more into 3 times 3 to realize it's a
perfect square but we could leave it
like that so this first term right here
we can write as
the square root of 2 times 2
times the square root of 5 times the
square root of 9 times the square i'm
going to put the square root of 9 out
front so square root of 2 times 2 times
the square root of 5 times the square
root
of
9.
now what is this second term equal to so
let's factor it out
405 that is 5 times i think it's 81 but
just to verify
405 5 goes into doesn't go into 4 so
let's go into 40 5 goes into 40 eight
times 8 times 5 is 40
subtract you get a 0 bring down the 5 5
goes into 5 one time right 81 times 81
is 9 times 9. you could factor more if
we were trying to do the the fourth root
or something like that we want to just
do a square root and we have a 9 and a
9. so no need to factor anymore so this
second expression right here is plus
6
times the square root of 9 times 9 9
times 9 times the square root of 5.
so let us so what is this this is 3
this is 2 right this is the square root
of 4 so 3 times 2 is 6. so we have 6
square roots of 5
plus
what's this right here the square root
of 9 times 9 the square root of 81
that's of course just 9. so 6 times 9 is
54. so plus 54
square roots
of
5 and then what do we have left what do
we have left we have six of something
plus 54 of something that's going to be
equal to 60
of that
something
just like that let's just do one more
and we're going to we're having some
abstract quantities here we're going to
deal with some variables but i really
just want to do it to show you that the
variables don't change anything
let's say if we have the square root or
the principal root of 48 a
and i'm going to add that to
i'm going to add that to the square root
of 27
a
so once again let's factor let's just
factor the 48 part we'll leave the a
aside so 48 is 2 times 24 which is 2
times
12 sorry 2 times 12 which is
3
times
4. so you have so we can rewrite this
first expression here as the square root
of 2 times 2
times the square root of 4
times the square root of 3. now you
might have done it a quicker way you
might have just factored into 3 and 16
and immediately realize that 16 is a
perfect square but i did it you know
just kind of the brute force way you'd
get the same answer either way
and of course not just the square root
of 3 you also have the square root of a
there so i'll just put the a right over
here i can put in a separate square root
but both of these aren't perfect squares
so i'll both i'll leave both of these
under the radical sign
now 27
is 3 times 9 9 is a perfect square root
so we can stop there so the second term
we can rewrite it as the square root of
nine times the square root
of three a and both of these you can
kind of use i'm skipping an intermediate
step the intermediate step i could have
written it first as i could have written
that first expression as the square root
of 9 times 3a and then gone to this step
but i think we have enough practice
realizing that 9 times 3a all of that to
the one-half power or taking the
principal root of all of that is the
same thing as taking the principal root
of 9 times the principle root of 3a so
that's the step i skipped in both of
these but hopefully that doesn't confuse
you too much
and so this term right here is going to
be a 2 this term right here is going to
be a 2 so this is going to be 4 times
the square root of 3a
and then this over here this right here
is a 3. so this is going to be plus 3
times the square root of 3a
4 of something plus 3 of something will
be equal to
will be equal to 7 of the
something anyway hopefully you found
that useful